netanyahu's time in power in israel is
finally over
this evening after a coalition of
parties won a majority
in that country's parliament the
long-serving leader was defiant
before the vote and said we will be
back skies mark stone is in jerusalem
uh so mark uh the end of an era well is
it the end of an era or is it
uh is it really just another
interruption
it's the end of an era for now if you if
you could say that certainly 12 years
in power a man that has been the center
of israeli politics the center of
regional politics and geopolitics for so
many years
is now in opposition and we've just been
watching pictures from inside the
knesset as he
unceremoniously uh moved himself from
the
seat that the prime minister takes over
to the seats that the
leader of the opposition takes and that
will be where he now sits until he comes
back
and he says he will uh he says that um
he is the only man that can defend the
nation it wasn't
all that long ago mark just a few weeks
ago that you and i were standing here in
jerusalem
talking about how benjamin netanyahu had
because of the recent conflict in gaza
once again cast himself as the defender
of the nation it's something he's cast
himself as for many many years and it's
resonated
with voters to an extent but politics
has now caught up with him even during
that conflict
in gaza he knew that this moment would
come that there would be an attempt by
a very very strange mix of opposition
parties to come up with the numbers come
up with a coalition to be able to remove
him
from power and so they have done tonight
and it is a very very strange mix
of um of political leaders from
opposition parties ranging from the new
prime minister
naftali bennett a man further to the
right than benjamin netanyahu is a
a religious israeli jewish nationalist a
man who doesn't believe in the
palestinian state for example
a very very hard right up certainly if
his rhetoric is to be believed he is now
in bed politically
with a centrist an anchorman journalist
turned centrist politician yaya lapid
the
the architect of this strange coalition
and it goes further too there is
an israeli arab among the the front seat
of this coalition
uh agreement as well that the fact that
these three men
and five others could sit together many
people thought that wasn't possible but
tonight
here in jerusalem in the knesset they
have voted
to to form this coalition government it
is being sworn in
as we speak